Silicon Valley some major changes this
year from new technology that filters
out hate speech on social media to push
for gender equality this morning we are
highlighting some of the biggest stories
and new developments we covered in 2017
as we take a look back at a year in tech
Apple's new flagship iPhone is the most
expensive phone it has ever produced we
call this face ID face book revealed
Russian agents bought roughly 3000 ads
for about 100,000 dollars during the
2016 campaign I don't want anyone to use
our tools to undermine democracy we have
created tools that are ripping apart the
social fabric of how society works
they've spent the last year trying to
make you Instagram nicer uber promises
an urgent investigation into sexual
harassment claims I've had lots of
conversations over the years with women
who told me horror stories about being
sexually harassed in Silicon Valley
Equifax is dealing with fallout this
morning over its massive data breach you
may be wondering why it took over a year
to disclose the stolen data their belief
was okay we'll pay them they'll delete
it everything will be fine
Alexa how many tablespoons are in 3/4
cup we say things and they hear things
that we really wouldn't want everywhere
I think we should be cautious as you
just saw a CBS News contributor and
wired editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson
covered these stories for us throughout
the year he's looking forward to what we
can expect in 2018 Nick good morning I
know we're wrapping up the year knocking
forward one of the things we have to
deal with those we saw Google Facebook
Twitter all testified before Congress
about Russian interference in our
elections where does that take us well
there's gonna be that specific
investigation we'll go further but what
I think it really shows is it shows
there has been or is a moral reckoning
ongoing right now with the tech industry
where they're really thinking about the
influence they've had on the world the
influence they have on us and a lot of
that was triggered by the influence they
had on the election where they thought
wait a second were we responsible for
the hostility in the election where we
responsible for what happened and that
has caused a lot of introspection do you
hurt I mean you heard Tim Cook the head
of Apple use the words I think maybe for
the first time
moral responsibility yeah absolutely
you've seen them all talk about their
moral responsibility and you saw just
this week Facebook saying you know we've
been studying whether social media is
good for you crazy yeah right that
Facebook is actually saying we're gonna
take a look back and we're gonna decide
whether the thing we do is good it turns
out it is if you use it actively it's
not if use it passively it was a pretty
interesting study they put out so do you
think that Silicon Valley is now
becoming more introspective taking stock
yes absolutely I think that is the
biggest shift between this year and last
year in the old days you know three
years ago four years ago there are lots
of people on the outside saying Silicon
Valley you're the most powerful
companies in the world you change the
way we relate to each other you change
everything about our lives think about
it seriously and there's say no yeah ok
ok yeah and then this year so long they
denied that they had that kind of an
influence and impact and they don't deny
it anymore yeah what about sexual
harassment in Silicon Valley so you saw
it's starting to come out you saw people
starting to get in trouble the thing
that actually I think captivates Silicon
Valley and is the most important is
gender equity because the algorithms
that are being written now will shape
all these platforms and all this
technology and if all the algorithms are
written by men then you have a big
problem because that's the technology
that shapes society down the road so
it's actually sexual harassment is a big
issue but it's not quite like the way it
works in media it's happening at a
slightly different level this is so
interesting because this is really Jodie
Cantor's point in The New York Times
about exposing everything it's who
writes the stories to us who writes the
narrative who makes the decisions
who writes who's the engineers who write
the code and all that stuff and that's a
really interesting way to think about
all of this right because if you write
an algorithm and it's based on an image
set and the image set has a bunch of
stock images and all the people who it
sees in a kitchen are women right then
it writes an algorithm for the way a
robot will act and then suddenly you
have robots acting based on this gender
bias dataset you've got huge problems
down the road so you need somebody to
stop that at some point and it's more
likely a woman will notice that so
that's like a very simple explanation of
a complex problem but it's something
Silicon Valley is thinking about a lot
now thanks for Twitter yeah new rules
for Twitter to curb hate yes what does
that mean for the future Twitter well I
mean Twitter has a really hard problem
incorrectly based on the culture based
on the structure of the
based on how easy it is anonymous
accounts well Instagram yeah you know
what one of the big things in the year
was all these companies trying to curb
hate Instagram has a much easier time
doing it then Twitter because Twitter is
a much more open fast-moving political
forum Instagram it's much subtler but
Twitter says they're gonna suspend every
users yes starting today if you're
associated with a hate group you're gone
so that's gonna be interesting how they
define hate group and who they knock off
they're gonna get messy there goes that
that's that moral responsibility there
it is yeah all right Nick Thompson
thanks so much for being with us